GAMES IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
PUCK SENT IN ON GOAL BY Y  ATTE.
STOPPED AND TROVENT SCORE,
2-0 LEAFS!
FOR MITCHELL MARNER, WITH AN OU
PASS.
RETRIEVES THE PUCK AND MARNER N.
McKEGG OUT IN FRONT FOR REAVES.
HE SCORE DEFENSEMAN
FROM THE PUCK AND FOX IS RIGHT
PLAY.
>> Kenny: MATTHEWS WITH THE
F T.
NOW TROUBA.
MILLER WITH A SHOT.
REAVES SHOOTS AND SCORES
EVENTUALLY WHACKS THAT PUCK UP
AND GETSHE PUCK
ALIVE FOR PANARIN.DES .
PANARIN WITH A LONG SHOT.
BLOCKED.
THEN THE FLIP PASSR TWO OVERALL.
CENTERING PASS AND KREIDER IS
.
SHOT BY LINDGREN.
THEY SCORE
STICK OF NYLANDER BLOCKS IT BUT
IT'S HEADED RIRIN.
ALL EYES O KREIDER.
CAMPBELL ALMOST KEPT THAT OUT.
GRETZKY.
CROSS-PASS FROM RIELLY.E THE DE
FACTOR HERE FOR THEM BRINGING
THIS ONE AS HE EMPTY NET AND HE
SCORES BACKHAND.